since I come from LA I've barely ever
even seen snow before that's an adorable
11 year old Joseph gordon-levitt
the first time we met him back in 1993
three years later he would star as an
alien stuck in the body of a teenager on
3rd Rock from the Sun out in the world
people are nice but in high school who
aren't mature enough to deal with it
they're like you're on TV I don't know
if you've been able to give yourself a
quarantine haircut but would you
consider is now the time to bring back
that ponytail yeah excellent question
I will consider it it would take a while
that was a lot of dedication next year
marks 25 years since the premiere of 3rd
rock and get this 10 Things I Hate About
You came out over 20 years ago Kenny
you've been part of so many beloved
casts are there any talks of any zoom
reunions in the works oh man yeah well
um David Krumholtz from 10 Things I Hate
About You I mean we're always in touch
now the dad of two and four year old
voice has a six-part YouTube mini-series
create together 10-minute episodes all
about how people are coping with the
pandemic by being creative we pitched
the show like four weeks ago we started
producing it like three weeks ago and
it's premiering now most people are
eating cheese and drinking like I just
got to get through and you're like let
me make a TV show broke oh I'm eating
some cheese don't worry
[Music]